Там есть английский язык, и я просто его перевернул в английском, и это выглядит, что он работает.
Ставь на моем сайте.
Окей, нажимай кнопку "Sign In" и скажи мне, что ты видишь.
Попробуйте регистрацию на твоей e-mail.
"Sign In" просто кнопку "Sign In" есть "Join Meeting" или "Open App".
Попробуйте, потому что уже у меня есть аккаунт logged in.
Попробуйте "Log Out".
У меня есть много разных вариантов, которые очень удобны, как Google и Microsoft.
Я уже использую Google и это работает perfectly, обои сайт и телефона.
Поп-оп says: "They've sent me an email".
"Do you want me to go into my Gmail or is it just, like, I have, the email has come through, I can confirm it?"
- Ну, open your Gmail, try to open this email and link. If it's successful, say it. If not, tell me what you see. And after a few minutes, try to open this link again. It should be expired. And what's the error you see?
В общем, я не знаю, что это работает.
Я не знаю, что я не знаю, что я не знаю, но я не знаю, что я не знаю, что я не знаю.
Добавил субтитры DimaTorzok
ok, я использую АИАссистенту, чтобы поменял свой паспорт
turns out I don't have a password, nor do I need one
and it's explained that quite clearly, very quickly
try to log out and sign in
and put the button to restore password
or forgot the password
Когда я звоню с emailом, это не требует пункта. Я звоню с Google или ссо.
Как вы загрузили в следующий раз? Вы просто получаете один-часовый код?
Без паспорта?
Когда вы звоните, мне кажется, что только один-часовый код и нет паспорта.
Хорошо, давайте перейдем.
Делайте свой аккаунт, если вы найдете какой-то кнопкой.
Продолжение следует...
Субтитры сделал DimaTorzok
Я не знаю, я думаю, что я должен быть в том, чтобы я не смогла проверить это.
Смотрите.
Maybe I should...
Okay, let me create something first.
I'll create...
Okay.
So this will be able to tell if when I delete my account, I'll log in if it's creating
a new account or signing back in.
How old was he again?
How old was he?
Give it back?
Yeah, alright.
Give it back.
Okay, let's try signing back in with the exact same thing and see if my logo is still
there.
I don't think one must be efficient.
There's no way, because you've got to have a lot of access to that.
No, code sending is very quick. This is very seamless.
Ah, okay, so it seems like it does actually delete your account, the stuff that I added before, isn't there?
That does seem to be working.
Yeah, yeah.
So in the instructions, maybe I should register through...
It does say to register through SSO or Google if available.
That'd be outrageous!
Would you like me to try registering through Google?
See if that changes the outcome.
Или, в самом деле, я сделаю это, чтобы проверить, если я могу...
Я думаю, что нет причины попробовать с Google или с сфер-мейлами.
Я просто...
Я пробовал самую вещь,
просто собираюсь в сфер-мейл в сфер-мейл,
без сфер-мейл-сфер-мейл.
Я собираюсь в сфер-мейл в сфер-мейл и вижу, что я уже есть аватар.
Так что я собираюсь в сфер-мейл на сфер-мейл или сфер-мейл,
но сфер-мейл-сфер-мейл.
Так что это же самое.
Сфер-мейл в сфер-мейл.